hello and welcome to part 5 of machine
learning for the use of algorithmic
trading where we left off from a this
percent change function but we haven't
actually tested this percent change
function one of the main issues with
this is going to be that it's not gonna
be willing to work with whole numbers
and give us a decent output so for
example let me just show you percent
change and let's do five eight it
returns a zero but what if we did
percent change five point zero
no change but now it returns the correct
60 percent change so what's actually
happening here well python naturally
wants to deal with whole numbers so if
we do like eight divided by five we get
one but if we do eight divided by five
point zero then we get one point six the
correct result that we really wanted so
python naturally just wants to make it a
whole number so there's a couple of ways
that you can get around this you can
either import division or you can add a
decimal here and this just notifies
Python hey we want to use decimals even
if you do a point zero so a couple of
spots that we might want to do this is
here and then here we could throw in
something like a float and basically
this is we'll just convert that point to
a float so I'm going to show you guys
real quick so let's say x equals five
and if we do y equals low x print out y
it's converted Y to a five point zero so
it's still the same value it's just
putting it into a decimal or what's
known as a float in programming so now
our percent change formula is a little
bit better there's still one more flaw
to it but we'll get there now the next
thing that we want to do is actually
make this pattern finer so what we're
gonna call it is actually a pattern
finder I know yeah you can see that name
coming I try to choose really weird
names now the first thing that we need
to do is where are we going to look for
these patterns well probably the best
place to look will be in the file so
let's just go ahead and and take this
and instead of having it right here
let's just make this global and we'll
put this down here
hmm and good now the next thing that we
want to do is also keep in mind now that
we've moved this if we decided to
manipulate these variables at all down
here we would need to global you know
global and the variable just just keep
that in mind but as long as you don't
manipulate the variables themselves
it'll be fun
so pattern finder first thing we want to
do is let's simplify this because as you
probably starting to see weird as we go
on there's gonna be a lot of variables
here and as long as we continue on with
bid-ask kind of prices it's gonna get
really really messy and we might not
ever actually finish this series so the
best thing for us to do is to just make
it a simple average of the average line
so to do that we ran it's just do
average line equals and then in here we
want to do bid plus ask and then divided
by two so this is just gonna Everage bid
and ask so to give us perfectly the
middle spot of between bid and ask and
now so now you can see why i we're why
we've thrown away spread and why i just
wanted to point it out to you guys
initially because we're not going to be
touching spread for quite a while if at
all now the next thing we want to do is
right we're going to look for patterns
in here and then after we as we look for
all these patterns the next thing we
want to do is for every pattern we find
we want to know what the outcome of that
pattern is so so with that we're gonna
say we're just going to say x equals the
length of average line and after we find
that pattern we're gonna look 30
patterns into the future 20 to 30 right
we're gonna look for the range of
between 20 and 30 and we're gonna
average the outcome like between 20 and
30 what's the average price right and so
from there we'll get the average outcome
between 20 and 30 and so that's what we
can a rate of basically the average
number in the future that we can kind of
hope to achieve right so if
only hits like this number for like a
split second right we won't want to call
that the outcome so instead we're gonna
take a range of numbers average them and
say okay this is the outcome so because
of that we're gonna look also 30 digits
into the future so and we're gonna use X
as like a counter so I guess before I do
what I was gonna do I'll show you why
why it's kind of funny I'll show you why
one anyways wasn't planned now the next
thing I want to do is y is going to be
the starting points that we use so Y
could equal let's say I'm trying to sign
because you'd want to have the percent
change even though really I think it
should not it ought to be 10 I will just
call it 11 just to be safe and just
ignore the first point now the next
thing that we're going to want to say is
Wow
Y is less than X now the reason why
we're going to add a while loop is we're
going to make it into a counter and so
every every pattern will do plus one and
log that pattern so now Y is greater
than X now you can understand why
because we're going to make this into a
counter eventually we're gonna hit the
length of average line and then when we
go to look for what happened in the
future we're gonna it's not going to be
available so that's why we need to throw
in a minus 30 here so make sure you do
that and so x equals the length of
average line minus 30 so it will stop at
the - thirtieth X basically that way we
can still look into the future
now here we want to say P 1 equals P 1
equals and it's going to be percent
change of what it's going to be average
line and then where are we in that
average line we're at Y minus 10 for the
starting point right so that's this is
the starting point now where are we
currently well we're at a ver egde line
and we're at Y minus
why minus 9 so for every point along
this way like p1 will just be literally
point 1 in this pattern so for every
point along the way the starting point
will remain the same as I said we could
change this but for now we will not and
so this y minus 10 will always be the
same but we're gonna change the ending
part and so the easiest way to do this
is since we have 10 points and a lot of
this will be the same we'll just paste
so 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and then let's go
ahead and edit these so 2 3 4 5 and 10
now the only other thing that changes is
these here so to be Y minus 8 7 6 5 4 3
2 1 and then you could do y minus 0 but
we'll just say Y now so that's point 1 2
3 or 6 on an exam now the next thing we
want to do is we want to say what is the
outcome range right and that's going to
be average lime and the range of
outcomes is y plus 20 all the way to y
plus 30 so basically the the 10 numbers
between whatever Y is at the time plus
20 all the way to y plus 30 so it's a
this produces an array of 10 points then
what we want to do is what's our current
point and that's just going to be
average lime why why not really need
this in the future but we'll use that
for now and just for printing out
function now the next thing we need to
do is we want to average the outcome of
this so for now we'll just print that
out so we're gonna print and we're gonna
use lambda to do this if you don't quite
follow I do have a tutorial on lambda
but otherwise just copy what I do it's
just a really quick way for us to
average we're going to print reduce and
what are we going to do we're going to
do
lambda X comma Y and we're gonna do X
plus y and then for that where you use
outcome Grange and then we're gonna
divide that let me see here what about
yeah it's good land of outcome range so
it's just it's basically you know adds
everything together so for every x and y
it's just gonna add them together and
with an outcome range and then it's
going to divide it by the length of the
outcome range otherwise known as average
now next thing we'll do is let's just
print current point like a little spacer
here and then we'll just do print p1 p2
p3 p4 p5 p6 p7 p8 p9 and 10 and finally
do we have sleep now so go up to the top
and import time if you're gonna copy me
I'm just gonna make something that
pauses with asleep
so we'll do time got sleep but at the
end of this function after you know this
is basically the storage of one pattern
if we leave this like this Y will always
be less than X and we will just get a
bunch of the same pattern so what we
need to do at the end of this function
and I shall put it before the sleeper
well just do you do put y plus equals
one so this just is a shorthand way to
add one to the variable Y now let's go
ahead and save this and let's run
pattern finder and see if if everything
is worked so come over here and it
should take a second to load on start
because what it's doing is it's loading
up gbp/usd one-day dot text into your
RAM so in creating these arrays so
that's being loaded into your memory so
every time you load it's going to take
some time and that's why we global this
variable because otherwise if you put it
like maybe down here it would be doing
that a lot anyway yeah more on that
later excites another thing that we'll
run into in a little bit so what we want
to run is pattern finder enter and sure
enough basically what we've done is
we've printed the outcome first
so the
come you can actually see the outcome is
slightly higher than the current point
that we're on and so even though this is
just really it's a pattern but in theory
this pattern is a pattern of profit for
in the in the tone of what well not even
a full pip like a half a pip well anyway
we can see here we've got you know - you
know a tiny percent - a 20% - - - might
actually a lot of - percentage but
anyway in the future we can see that
after all of these little - percentage
and if you plot this up it would make a
pattern of some sort we can see in the
future it does produce a half a pip
so or a little bit less but basically
you have a pip
and so a little bit of money but anyway
that's one pattern now what we're gonna
want to do is begin a whole storage of
all of these patterns and then we can
start to compare against patterns so
anyways that's the storage of a single
pattern in the next video we'll continue
building off of this as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions and until next time